good morning good afternoon good evening
depending on where you're joining us
from
welcome to simply learn we are honored
to have you join us today for uh big
data
apache hive
with syed
my name is richard and after this intro
i'll be mostly in the background helping
syed so that everything goes smooth big
data in hadoop and the apache hive or
hql
as technology explodes around the world
big data field explodes with it and
hadoop is
the number one big data processor and
apache hive is definitely one of the
most powerful tools out there for
processing and pulling that information
out
if you do not know syed syed is a big
data hadoop consultant working with the
best in town analytics eureka and simply
learn a hadoop expert with a background
as a senior software engineer and
project lead he carries certifications
and expertise in hepatia dupe the data
scientist toolbox mongodb getting and
cleaning data our programming pnp
and a number of others for the last half
a decade basically everything big data
i'm excited to have syed here today i am
proud to introduce syed who will be your
host for big data hadoop and hive
go ahead sit back relax have a cup of
coffee tea or if it's in the evening
where you're at maybe a glass of wine
and enjoy it's an honor for me to hand
this over to syed thank you and happy
learning
syed
hey richard hi so nice to hear from you
oh it's great having you here today i'm
gonna go ahead and meet myself and let
you take over
all right thank you so much that is
quite some audience uh thank you so much
richard and thank you so much for such a
wonderful introduction as always
um
hello everyone this is sayad here a very
warm welcome to all of you all um
um thank you so much for joining this
session uh on on on big data and
uh apache hype
um
uh let me just kind of quickly give you
a brief on how i usually go about my my
session uh those of you hi shake
uh those of you who have been already
attending my uh
my my sessions would know that i really
have this habit of creating a cheat
sheet or a toc cheap table of content
sheets like this like this over here
that you see on your screen
uh i keep uh you know i
usually what i do is that i just list
out the content uh listed on the items
that i will be taking in my presentation
and keep coming back over here and
marking it let me give you an example
um which as richard is just not giving
my uh
my my introduction i'll just come over
here and make it as as done
and this is how you know i will keep
doing it i will keep hello suresh i will
keep uh marking uh these you know these
individual
content items done as i am going to keep
uh covering it for you
uh if you have questions in your in your
mind you can kind of you know just note
it down separately as richard said um
indeed towards the end of the session
we'll have a
15-20 minutes question and answer
session where i am going to pick up
you know sessions and answer questions
and and answer
them for you
right so enough about the structure
let's get the ball rolling
uh
and before i really start uh telling you
uh uh hi prasad hi hi uh
hi hi hello
uh before i uh really uh kind of you
know carry on with the content just to
give you an idea about how i'm planning
to go about this session is uh i'm going
to give you a little bit of idea about
big data and hadoop uh i'll do a sample
run on on for you uh in terms of uh you
know one small file maybe one big file
and then i'm going to quickly jump into
hive tell you about hype components
which is essential for you to you know
get an idea about what um you know is
all about
hive design high architecture by way of
uh basically um you know ppt or graphic
uh gravity and graphics and um you know
something like higher tables and then
i'm going to let me just write this down
this is the beauty of
you know this instructor i can keep
adding things into it so i've uh let me
write it like this
i
queries if the time permits i've also
prepared something on json but let me
see if i if i get time i'm going to run
that also for you amazing so that's what
the background is let's get started
let's let's get the ball rolling all
right so this session is about hive the
session about big data this session is
about hadoop this session is about
everything that has to do with big data
and everything that has to do with
analyzing big data using hadoop and
hives isn't it
so first of all why don't we understand
a little bit about what is big data
right the other day a gentleman was
asking me i think one of the students
from one of my badges was asking me what
is big data and how big is big data
what i asked him is
[Music]
how much is the hardest size of your
laptop
right he said one terabyte i said by any
chance in your organization maybe you
are using a desktop or is it the size of
your desktop or how much is the hardest
size in your desktop two terabytes four
terabytes
what i told them is that any data which
your individual computer on which you're
working your single computer on which
you're working it can it cannot hold it
is beyond the storage capacity of that
machine is big data
right you need distributed setup you
need cluster of computers
for you to save that kind of data and
let me tell you my friends
saving is not the only thing
you also need to manage you also need to
process it you also need to do some
business analytics on it you also need
to do some meaningful work on top of it
so that it becomes advantageous for you
right so that's why you need it that's
why you need it now when we talk about
this kind of data and by the way volume
and size is not the only aspect there
are other aspects as well i'm not going
to delve deeper into it usually in my
big data hadoop class sessions i i go
deeper into it
i'm only going to you know just just
skim through the surface because we
really have to get into uh get into the
topic uh so you know if it is big data
then it it basically throws uh you know
these two kind of challenges one
challenge is basically in front of you
uh which is uh which is the storage as i
said and the other is processing
storage and processing are two major
challenges which
big data can throw in front of you
and hadoop is a technology which
basically helps you solve those
challenges
right hadoop is a technology which
basically provides two parts
hdfs hadoop distributed file system
which by the way is based on the google
white paper
which basically takes care of
the
the storage of big data and mapreduce
which takes care of the processing of
big data
right
right it takes care of the processing of
big data right a formal definition
whatever i just said is something which
is written over here over here storage
and processing a formal definition of
quickly of hadoop is this apartheid is
an open source framework meant to
provide an automated disability
computing environment it has got two
parts hdfs and mapreduce as simple as
that
it solves those two problems
of big data
fine very good fdfs takes care of
storage
mapreduce takes care of processing
but then mapreduce code has to be
written in a programming language
primarily in hadoop the programming
language is java
and not everybody is that comfortable
with the programming language
people need a higher level of
abstraction
people need an easy thing to use
interface
and easy to use interface for them to do
their work to do their analytics right
and that is where hype comes into
picture right let me give you a big you
know brief background of that and let me
in the meantime just keep on completing
marking things which are done for you
therefore really i get into eight uh let
me quickly run uh
an example for you uh so i'm sure you
would have definitely done this if
you've got some or the other background
of hadoop you would know that you know
how to run this kind of program hadoop
home
lib x
uh let me just quickly do that for you
later
and done this you know program
we can say that
give me one second
uh
word count say
i have an input file called as test.txt
i have an output file called as output
go ahead and on your program that's all
typical typical you know how to program
um
okay directly already created so i'll
just go ahead and quickly uh delete the
directory i'll say fs rm i'm assuming
that you guys already know all this so
not spending much time on it
uh really
um
now i'll go ahead and done my job so
there you go
right so this is how typically uh you
know hadoop job you know looks like when
it runs uh i'm running this job in a
small file called this test.txt which
has some some you know some some v small
uh you know
not not that big output
uh i'll also run the same program on uh
another file which is slightly uh more
bigger and while that program would be
running will slowly move on to high in
the in the essence of time
and you know carry it on from there
so that's for you that's where you are
let me just give you a quick idea about
what this file is all about class
test.txt this was inside this file
uh
txt this is a wonderful wonderful
wonderful session isn't it is it not yes
it is
and uh if i go here and say
ls and say
outward
let's go ahead and give the output you
can get
you can get the get get this as an
output
part dash r dash
one two three four five um do a cat
operate basically it's gonna do
uh the record of all those entries which
were there inside the ah inside my input
file so this is a session wonderful so
whatever has come three times it was
given three times uh in the input it has
counted it it does three times amazing
very good a simple program why don't we
go ahead and turn a bigger program which
is let's say
on a bigger file so let me just show
this to you ls minus l
slash i've got a bigger file which is uh
uh which is exactly kislam showing the
traditional uh traditional traditional
map producer yeah so there's a there's a
there's a file.txt i'll just go ahead
and and i don't know program with this
file.txt which is one gb file i'm gonna
get started with my with my run another
file and then we can basically um run
right so this program will start and
okay so i need to delete the output
folder again so do fs
rm
output
and i'll go ahead and
run the program again
right so now this program will run
that is going to take some time to run
right so let it dry and you know for
whatever time it takes
so um
[Music]
you come back here hadoop sample run
this is what we have been doing just now
so so then you know what what is the
need uh you know what are the need for
hype as you would see the program i've
taken is from um you know from the api
where the code was already given you
know for you but if you have to write
this program you have to like this kind
of code right i have opened another
program but you can see that you'll have
to write a typical word current program
would have three files word count
background mapper too much of java code
right and you know that in order for you
to write java code you have to
basically you know put in a lot of
efforts you will have to uh you know
basically jot down the requirement do
programming do unit testing then sid
then uat then you know it will go to
production and the support and there's a
whole lot of life cycle associated with
it right
usually people don't have so much time
and usually they want to do some quick
finalists and listen on the same kind of
same kind of data that is where the
framework like i just come into picture
right so see my program is running it'll
take at least five minutes to run
because the the data
it's only just one gb imagine if the
data would have been one derivative it
would have taken even you know more uh
you know bigger time fair enough very
good let it let it run so why hype then
let's jot down all these you know these
are typical typical you know questions
so hive so that we can
have a
simplified uh
simplified
interface
to
perform your
analytics
it was basically developed at facebook
where they actually had
where they actually had uh
more and more of people who were
comfortable with database programming
right more and more people who are
comfortable with database programming so
they want to develop a higher level of
of interface a higher abstraction
um which basically looks like
looks like like database or sql
interface so need for a
higher
level abstraction
i'm answering the question why hive over
here for you
a need for level of abstraction
uh need for a higher level of
abstraction which
which which
basically
sits on top of hadoop
and
basically sits on top of hadoop
and yet provide
provides
you
an interface interface to do your big
data
analytics
right
it was developed
at facebook
where majorly
majorly the team members
were
well worsened with
database
program
so they wanted uh to have a similar um
you know kind of uh interface for them
amazing very good so that's why you
needed um you know hi um why high right
that's why you need high
i'm marking it over here hey what is
height then let me show you a slide for
you to understand what hive is
get out of here a little bigger for you
maybe and then uh you know i'll show it
to you in full screen
give me one second
yeah
so this is what type is a hadoop based
big data data warehousing
and it sits on top of basic hadoop
cluster it supports something called as
high quality language we will quickly
see an example a few of them which is
similar to sql you'll see this the
similarity of it it provides the
facility to analyze large data set
stores in hadoop by way of an
easy-to-use interface
like it has got a shell called as hive
shell
this interface sits on top of basic
hadoop cluster it converts each and
every high query into map reduce program
let's see example of that the cluster
finally execute these query
on the
not this is not the cluster just give me
one second i'll just change the
the shell the interface interface
finally execute these queries on the
cluster this hive interface the shell
interface finally execute these queries
on the cluster
okay this is what what is
it's basically
called formally called as data
warehousing tool of a
right because it helps you do business
analytics in a patch oriented manner
with a simplified interface
right with this simplified providing a
simplified interface so that's the
formal uh definition of it uh my friends
quickly i just showed it to you
um
right let me tell you a couple of you
know important hype components quickly
to you
i basically comprises of
you know four different very very
important components a driver
a compiler
a meta store and an execution engine and
let me tell you how they kind of you
know collaborate with each other to
execute your query on the hadoop cluster
driver is the first component
where basically when you write your
query
on a hive shell
it it it basically
you know passes your query
for your uh you know for your validation
in terms of the syntax
and then pass it on further on to the
compiler component right this is the
shell let me uh why don't i go ahead and
just give me one second
give me one second
i'm just opening another
this
yeah
so there you go i'm starting a hive
shell and i'll tell you it's going to
start in some time i'm going to tell you
how it looks like in some time
right let it get started so uh there you
are it's starting so so the driver is
that component which basically
intercepts and passes your query
name write your you know query over here
and it basically intercepts it and
passes it now if you see the queries
here on the eye hive shell it will look
similar to you as you would write query
on a
on a mysql or a sql interface something
like this show databases
right that will show you all the
databases that i have created one
database over here right and i'll create
a couple of more databases over here
right so this is the shell where behind
the scene there's a driver running
there's a driver working which is
basically
right which is basically passing your
query
and for the validation it's very good
now once that validation is over
once that validation is over what this
driver does is it passes on that
information to compiler another
component right it passes on the
information to another uh like you know
another component which basically
is
which basically what it does is
basically creates an execution plan
right this compiler over this driver
over here asked the compiler
that you know can you create an
execution plan for me
so that i can execute it on the cluster
so that i can execute that plan on the
cluster
so compiler is that hype components
which creates the execution plan on the
request from the driver
and returns that execution plan to
driver right
returns that execution plan to the
driver
right returns the execution plan
the compiler creates this plan in
consultation with another component
called as metastore
right it concerns with another component
called as metastore now this meta store
is basically something which give me a
second
yeah
just one second yeah this meta store is
one component which basically uh is uh
is is is is basically basically
uh
you know stores meta information about
things that you do on your cluster
right about things that you do on your
cluster let me show you uh let me show
you a bit of uh you know information of
on how this uh
this meta store looks like let me show
the presentation for you
over here
yeah so a high meter store uh you know
basically uh looks uh looks like this
you have driver then you have got a meta
so meta store application and then there
is a
db as well database as well now if you
install hive in a pair you know
you know
pure vanilla interface directly pure
vanilla version directly downloaded from
the website what will happen is that the
database that you will get over here
over there is a derby database okay
which is basically uh not
any good for your
you know for your uh
you know for your development kind of
because it's single threaded only one
person can work on it
there's another kind of installation for
meta store called as
local meta store where you'll have you
know basically you can see two blocks
over here there's one block which is for
you know me myself and let's say this is
another block which is for you your
installation you'll have your driver
with your metastore application i'll
have my driver with my metastore
application and a separate database
which is outside of five can be
configured as a hive metastore db now
this database is an rdbis
right and in my state over here i have
mysql configured as a metastore
now
i have instructions on my blog and by
the way i write my blog as well where
you can do
you know uh
setup of your own as a
mysql configuration as hive metastatic
you can do setup of your own so let me
just share this with all of you all
so that uh later on uh me and richard
will share it share it with anyone who
has missed it i'm kind of you know just
not sharing it
you can configure your
metastore db your your your your
basically your mysql as a meta story so
i have my sql which is configured as a
meta store db for myself so while i've
started the hive shell over here i can
open another window here and open mysql
as well say you
night and if i say that show databases
here
it's more of an rdbms you can see meta
store schema is already created over
here
so the activities
essentially the ddl activities that you
will do over here
will get reflected will get saved
the metadata which will get generated
out of the ddl activities that you do
over here will get saved here
right we'll see examples of that but
basically
to give you an idea about what meta
store looks like this is what meta stove
looks like
right right there application and you
have a tv and then you have a production
version of it where even your meter
store application is load balanced so if
one of the drivers from one of you one
of the you from one of the uh kind of
you know interface is reaching out this
to this meta store jvm and there are
several people who are doing it and this
is maxed out in terms of the resources
the other interface can help you
cater to the additional request a
typical load balanced you know
production kind of setup so a meta store
is basically an application will which
helps you
save metadata that you create on the
iphone that gets created out of the
activities that you do on livestream
right the activities that you do on hive
shell amazing very good
so that means what what is compactly
doing with metastore then what is
compiled what compiler is doing is
compiler is that hive component which
creates an execution plan and returns it
back to the driver
right it basically create an execution
plan and returns it back to the driver
and just give me one second guys just
one second
[Music]
ah
sorry about that uh yeah so so compiler
is uh is that component uh you know
basically which which which uh which
which creates the execution plan and
what you can see over here is that i
have written that compiler creates this
plan with the help of the metastore
because metastore is saving that
metadata
it is storing that metadata it is
managing that metadata
right and it is persisting that metadata
in an rdbms
right so driver tells the compiler
can you create an execution plan
compiler says hold on
let me consult the meta store
who basically is managing the metadata
for it you have said you have written a
query called select start from employee
let me first of all go and check
table is there or not
only then i can create an execution
platform
only then i can go ahead and create an
execution plan for you um
right only then i can create an
execution plan for you just one second
here
yeah
right so and then when when when
metastore when when compiler is done
with consulting
and when compile is done with consulting
with metastore about the metadata it
goes back to the driver it creates the
execution plan and gives it back to the
driver
right usually what will happen is that
the compiler will create an execution
plan which will be either hdfs
operations
or a combination of hdfs operations and
mapreduce job
we will quickly see a couple of examples
of that
right you quickly see a couple of
examples of that and once that execution
plan is created it basically is passed
on to the
execution engine by the driver right the
execution engine is the high company
which executes the execution plan
created by the compiler let's come back
here and see how they work in practical
you can see this is these steps over
here
you can see these steps over here let me
just you know stretch it out for you
right you can see this step from one you
know uh steps uh starting from step
number one
from the ui where you are setting you
are saying execute query it comes to the
driver driver is going to the compiler
and asking the compiler can you give me
the plan compiler says hold on let me
get in touch with the meta store and
create uh you know and and basically you
know check whether the metadata is
relevant metadata is there in the
in the in the in the database or not
meta compiler checks the metadata
creates the plan gives it back to the
driver the driver gives it to the
execution engine execution engine
executes it on either hdfs via name node
or on both hdfs and and and and and map
reduce
taking into consideration both the parts
right so if you look at this graphic
basically the right hand side is more of
a hadoop cluster the left hand side is
more of hive
right where these one two three four
components are specified and how and and
shown how they and shown how they
collaborate with each other
driver the compiler the meta store and
the execution engine
right now that you know about these
components a little bit let me do one
thing let me just quickly go back here
and show you how they look like in
practice
right how they look like in practice
very good um
what do we do now we are on the shelf we
will say okay show uh databases we are
on the hive shell
right okay let's go ahead and create a
database create
database
simply
db
now what you will do what you will
observe over here is that
this is my metastore db
i am going to go here and say use meter
store i have still not created the
metastore db on hive shell
right
okay
then i'll come here and say
show
select
star from
dbs in fact if i say show tables over
here
i can see all these tables
i can see um
dbs table which will have metadata with
respect to database creation i can see
tbls table which will have metadata with
respect to with respect to tables
creation
right
select
star from
dbs if i do
basically tell me
have a row with respect to the test
database that is created
so so this is my hive shell this is my
mysql shell
and this is my
proper terminal from which i can do hdfs
operations so this basically acts like a
dashboard phone
right let's say hadoop fs dash ls over
here
and say
say enter
what will happen is i can see this user
folder over here let's come here and say
just one second
i'll come here and say user i'll go
inside my ui still not created the
database i want to show you certain
things before i do that
you can see this folder hive here and if
you go inside hive
you can see
a warehouse folder here
and then
inside warehouse
you can see a test.db folder created so
what happens is that the operations that
you do
over here on your hive shell results in
a structure that keeps on getting
created over here on your hdfs at this
location
this is called as high warehouse
location on hdfs
right
so the activities that you will do over
here if they are detailed activities
they will result in metadata which will
get stored in meta store db via behind
the scene meta store application
right yeah i repeat the activities that
you do over here which will result in
certain ddl
which are basically ddl activities which
will result in getting some metadata
created
will get saved in meta store db
via behind the scene meta store
application
right because if you'll find the query
over here
for the driver then the compiler then
meta store and then execution engine
will execute it
but ultimately what you're trying to do
is you're trying to manage data which is
big data so the big data will get saved
here at this location
we'll see examples of that let's go
ahead and create our database
one second
yeah
wow the database got created say
show databases now
yeah it simply db
has got created say use simply tv
you are in simply tv now say show tables
you don't have any tables over here the
interesting thing that you'll see over
here in your dbs table is
a row with respect to simply db is
created over here
right so that means you did some ddl
generation metadata generation activity
it resulted in creating a record over
here that means the data the metadata
which is getting created with respect to
your ddl activities over here is getting
saved over here in the metastatics
persistently
right
and over here on your hive warehouse
location if you now do ls
what you will see is that a simply db
tbs got created right so it is creating
a directory structure on hdfs and it's
creating metadata on
your
metastore db
right so a ddl activity would create
a database over here all fine
metadata over here in the metastar db
where it should and
a structure over here which is going to
hold big data
right
now i will go ahead and save some uh you
know some some data inside it so
i'll just come here and say by the way
all these files are available for you to
you know kind of use for your own
purpose for your own practice
um i'll say
okay i have this file over here which
has some data
okay so i've not created a table let me
just first of all go ahead and create a
table just one second
right so go ahead and create a table
let's say my customer my customer is the
table that i'm creating my customer has
got four fields in string string
uh string customer id first name last
name country
okay so the definition would look pretty
much similar to you like your
you know like your mysql definition
the only thing that you will see
different over here is that you have
this line over here it basically tells
whoever is creating this table
that this table is going to accept data
which is only separated by tab between
these columns
right
so i'll come here
i'll create the table right
now the table is created if i say show
tables now
it will show me one table my customer if
i come here
this should have generated some metadata
i'll say select
star from
pbls
just basically create a table my
customer for me right now the table is
created from a previous iteration of
this right so those tables are also
there and they are for different
different databases
so they are there we can ignore them
this is something which is got created
just now you know for me
id81 let me do uh gps also right so 76
this is the table which i have just got
created with respect to this tp
right amazing very good that means table
is also created let's go ahead and check
this inside the warehouse location
simply
db
not db if i do that
i'll see my customer is created if i go
inside my customer now
i wouldn't see anything inside it that
means it's asking for loading some kind
of data
right if i say select star from here
start from
from
my customer
will basically not show me any data that
means i need to load some data in it so
let me go ahead and load this data i
have this data at this location on my
local machine
user says desktop youtube examples hive
customer input.txt
into my customer right now if i do a
select start from my customer i can see
the data over here this was not a ddl
activity so no reflection over here but
i can come here and see that if i go
inside my customer
that file is copied over here
in fact to
to
kind of you know
cross check
i can do a
caterpillar
and check it whether it is the same data
set or not
yeah
so it is the same data
so that means it goes to show that if i
am doing activities which are
essentially ddl activities it will
generate metadata which will get stored
in metadata
but if i am basically loading the data i
am actually doing the act of loading the
data inside my
inside my
um you know inside my uh inside my htfs
so it gets loaded over here
i can create other kind of tables as
well so there are different kind of team
kinds of tables and this the table that
i created if you see over here it will
tell you that
it is a managed table wherein you
basically had the data you loaded the
table with the data you can create other
types of tables as well
right in which
you might not have the data but you'll
have the structure and you'll feel that
in future you will get the data
right in future you will get the data
those are tables those are kind of table
called as external table i've already
created this one for some of my match i
can create one for you
right now here itself right the syntax
will be slightly
hi look at the table uh look at that the
syntax it says create external
different kind of table here same
columns roll it delimited is also fine
but i'm giving the location as well
i'm saying my location is hadoop data
high stack external have some data over
there it will already start
showing to you
so say enter
okay
it has some problem with respect to
ah now it'll take it
i'll say enter and as i showed tables
my external table is also got created
now if i come back here now
and it says select star from dbls
you can see that this table is also
created
with the same id 76
right my table external with an id 177
that means by the act of creating table
was a ddl
activity it created a table over here
how about the data
i'll say select star
from
my customer
underscore external
no data why because at that location
there is no data as yet so i will go to
uh my
i'll go to my hdfs location
hadoop
fs
ls
slash hadoop data
right i'll go inside hi also
right and it has got
ext
there is nothing inside it right now so
what i can do is that i can say
where am i right now pwd so i can say cd
just
uh examples
hive
and i can put this data over here
i can say hadoop fs dash port
custom input.txt i can say
put this file inside
so explicitly putting the data at an
external location that's the reason why
it qualifies for the data for external
table i'll say cat and i'll say
come back here and say slash and say
customer input.txt
right if i come back here and say
my customer now i can see the data
so you use
internal tables or manage tables when
you have the data you know the structure
of it and you want to see it save it at
a high warehouse location
right
high whereas location which is this you
want hive to manage it but what if you
want to save the data at an external
location and you don't have the data you
feel that in future you will be getting
the data
right that is when you create external
so there are various different kinds of
tables that you can create now since
you've created the table and you since
you kind of you know
now have the data in the table now you
can do
you know almost all the things that you
can do in your sql tables you can create
joins you can create partitions you can
do sharding you can
like you know do performance you know
create views on top of it you can you
know apply your performance efficient
efficiency techniques
uh i don't think we have the time to you
know go through into all of those
details usually when i take this session
uh you know full height session i go you
know into it
so i'll just uh
you know leave it uh you know at this at
this point of time
you know five tables and i should show
you a couple typical queries by the way
these queries that i was writing over
here uh select star from and all and
load and everything this is what is the
ifql this is what is the high query
language
right
um so there's a lot more actually to say
but uh in the essence of time we have to
pick up the questions as well i would
just you know stop over here
and uh and and get back to
richard
um questions yeah
yes um i'm going to just for uh the
first few minutes of the question and
answer take over the screen for the poll
so i'm taking over the screenshot here
just for a little bit and let's go ahead
i think the first question i can go
ahead and answer give you a break for a
moment
uh there's a lot of questions as to is
this session recorded and will that be
available to reference later the answer
is yes we do record the sessions
they are usually posted within 24 hours
a lot sooner in most cases
and you can go to the simply learn help
desk and request for a copy of the
session and they'll send you the link
um and then that link is good i think
it's for 30 days it's either 30 or 45
days but i think it's 30 days
so that was one of the first questions
we had a lot of ques a lot of people
asking about
there is a question
somebody asked what is the difference
between
hive and pig maybe that's a brief one
you can answer while they're doing the
polling syed
yes it should see one of the basic
difference between hive and pig is that
the very very first thing is that hive
is
developed by facebook and pick is
developed by yahoo and so there are two
different vendors who have developed it
the two different places that they that
you know that they are developed
uh so that is one difference another
difference is that hive is typical pure
play
uh
database kind of uh you know you know
interaction interface pic is mostly a
programmatic or you know
transformational or what should i say
something like something like a you know
a javascript kind of simplified
interface the interfaces are different
right so
the inventors or the developers are
different the interfaces are different
the look and feel is different
and also in the entire hadoop life cycle
they are used for different different
purposes
so if you've gone through the business
analytics you know any business
analytics project and have an idea about
it you would know that
you know there are three stages in the
project uh this
summation and the presentation right
staging preparation
transformation collection so collection
preparation and presentation right so
pig is something which is basically used
at the
at the um you know preparation of the
transformation stage where you apply
business logic to your project hive is
something which is usually used at the
presentation stage in the last step
so there are different stages of the
life cycle where these uh you know where
these uh these are used so that i would
say the third difference richard
excellent yes that's what i would
definitely
um i was actually looking at the
questions i'm sorry there so yet i was
trying to look at the next questions i
was trying to pick out the ones that are
less technical while we're doing the
polling because they're easier to answer
the next question i have from cigar is
what is the difference between hadoop
and data analysis
or data scientist can you give a brief
description what those differences are
yeah so
see hadoop
usually the business the way business
analytics projects
work is that
see data scientist team does mostly the
number crunching and initial analysis
data data scientist team is the team
which basically
you know
looks out for it it's on a hunt for the
areas which are best suited for analysis
which can add dimensions to uh to the
revenue uh you know add to the revenues
and the profits of the company right and
basically give business ideas to the
business people
right so um so
so data scientists are those kind of
people they would be more adept with you
know skills in statistics
more adapted skills in our tableau and
more of the visualization
you know visualization tools
hadoop is basically at the technical
level hadoop is where they will do the
implementation in terms of mapreduce or
pig or hype
and then they will after doing that
implementation they are going to you
know this the hadoop team or the
technical team is basically going to
come and
come come back with a complete analysis
so data scientist team is something
which basically
starts the question starts the analysis
and gives the idea to the business
people
hadoop team of the technical team is
basically which
which writes the complete analytical
technical program in mapreduce or python
or whatever language and then gives the
complete answer to the question or the
analytical area which was initially
started by the data scientist so that's
how they are like you know segregated
uh richard
oh excellent excellent um
that's always that's one of the biggest
questions that i'm i get asked all the
time when i'm telling people what do you
know what is what is big data that's you
have to start with
i have a question from saranya
she was asking she noticed to use the
eclipse id
ide
for doing your programming and i've
known i've used the eclipse because i
find it easier for java and python
and the map to reduce and though i have
gotten the hadoop to work with netbeans
also um do you what is your thoughts on
that is there other ids or different
interfaces for doing that
i have seen that eclipse solve the you
know the purpose 90 of the time uh i
tell you what the very first reason is
it's free of cost it's open source
uh there are other good ideas uh like
like idea intellij for example
uh but then they are they all come for a
cost so in a in a in a official
environment you basically cannot use it
because you know you run into those
licensing concerns and issues
uh
in my short little career career of last
15 16 years i would say that you know
i've been using eclipse from what now 10
years now
and i think it fits the bill for
95 percent of the situations
so
i wouldn't suggest anybody moving from
anything other than eclipse
richard
oh excellent that's kind of what i have
found i found that i um because i do go
back and forth for some other things but
the eclipse seems to be
for an open source uh one of the best
ones out there
exactly exactly open source is is is the
key word over there richard
yes
let's see we have uh from i hope i can
say the right the name correctly mono
nano
um asking about user interface
frameworks and distinguishing between
the different hive user interfaces
um
i'm going to go ahead and give let's
give about another 30 seconds i don't
know if you need your screen to show
that
um
i believe if i understand the question
right he's asking for different
interfaces like you did it as a terminal
um there's also
what's he hue and stuff like that
for hives
yeah yeah so they basically you know
much more
basically conveniences so hugh is an
interface which is a much more
convenient interface to do whatever i
was doing on terminal it basically would
you know show you the table it's it's
more like uh you know i would say uh you
know windows explorer versus your
command prompt on windows
um you know from command prompt also you
can make directory and from windows
explorer also you can you can kind of
you know create directory but windows
explorer you would want to do it because
it's a simplified user interface command
prompt a programmer will go you know and
do a mkdir kind of thing so hue is a
simplified interface for you to do big
hive and an associated hadoop component
programming
uh
the the thing about you is that you have
to set it up once it is set up you can
use it for you know your purpose but
i've usually seen that
in a hive
program a hive uh querying from hive
terminals something with which basically
suffices if you need a more
sophisticated interface you can go for
you can go for uh for a queue
yes
but it doesn't add anything in terms of
the functionality of the framework and
you know per se richard
oh excellent okay
um let's see we have from
oh i'm going to get the name right
energy i hope i'm saying that close uh
what is the difference between hbase and
hive the two different storages in
hadoop the hbay storage and the hive
storage
ah so so first of all um the one of the
major difference between edge
between hive and edge base is that hive
is batch oriented hive is an abstraction
which is sitting on top of hadoop which
helps you
do what you do in hadoop in an easy and
you know simplified user interface
hbase on the other hand is a different
ballgame altogether edge base is
basically a nosql database a non-sql
database is a database which helps you
which helps you uh you know which helps
you do analytics in a real-time basis hb
is a nosql database or a hp database can
be plugged behind a real-time system
right if you've written a system which
is let's say developed in
dotnet or spring hibernate you can plug
that behind like an rdbms and the best
part about this is rdbms cannot be able
to manage big data
hbs will be able to handle big data in a
in a very very efficient manner
so hbase is a different category of
database data store i would say which
comes under the bigger category of nosql
database where mongodb is also there and
there are you know 50 other databases
hive is more of you know hadoop more of
batch oriented so batch oriented versus
real time is what the difference i would
say
richard
okay
excellent oh i'm learning stuff every
day on this
we'll keep the poll open for another
minute and it'll give back your screen
there was a question can we do the same
with the oracle database instead of
mysql from um
oh yes oh yes you can do that any
database of your choice you can
configure over here my friend any
database of your choice if you're
talking about mysqldb uh if you're
talking about metastore db you can
configure any database of your choice
and in fact my blog
over here
let me just come out of this uh which i
was suggesting my blog over here give
these instructions in this instructions
you can
this connector works for any rdbms right
the only thing that you need to do is
that in this in this hive shell you need
to give the corresponding driver and
your corresponding database connection
parameters whatever connection
parameters you give over here in this
xml file that very database it is going
to connect to as simple as that it is
very very simple
easy pc
oh yes it does make it a lot easier i'm
going to go ahead and close the polling
and then i have a couple more questions
here we can take
let's see i have
um
somebody was asking if you could go back
over uh the external keyword and a
little bit
on where the break is between external
and internal maybe a more
general yeah
actually i and these are the typical
questions which i keep getting in all my
sessions in the last four years richard
so i have created notes for it i tell
you what
so there you are there you are there are
three reasons why you would want to
you know have an external table versus
internal table i mean where you want to
decide whether you want to have an
external table or system type internal
table so first reason is when you feel
that you know the structure of the data
but you don't have the data in the
present moment then you will go for
external table you know the structure
but you don't have the data so you will
create the structure in your location
field you will give the reference to
you know that location field where you
expect the data to come in future then
you create the external table
you don't want second reason is you
don't want high success subsystem to
manage the data feed you want yourself
to manage it the moment you put your
data over here
in this location
this location hybrid starts managing it
right you don't want height to manage it
you want yourself to manage it that is
the second situation and you need uh
when you will create external table the
third is when you want another external
table to show the same data
let's say you've got 10 10 columns in
your table in your data set
and on top of it you want to create five
different tables or two columns each
right so you can create those interfaces
on same data set at the same external
location
right when you want to
create multiple views by way of table on
the same data you will create
dataset the reason why external tables
are created are our concept external
table is is has come into hive is so
that
you can create data structure without
having data expecting that in future you
are going to get the data and that's a
very typical scenario in any business
analytics project we talk about people
who revolve from the data warehousing
background uh richard you will see that
this is something which is their reading
better you know they'll say that on a
daily basis on an early basis they'll
keep getting data and you know
they don't know like you know what is
the kind of data is going to be so you
know and what are they going to do about
it you know whether they're going to
create multiple interfaces out on top of
it what interfaces best is put it at
some external location let the data keep
on coming let you know you go ahead and
create views on top of it
an external table is
a way to create those kind of views on
top of the data which is lying on html
right richard
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's amazing what kind of data you can
be in a job and they throw at you and
they don't really think to ask you what
they're sending they just hand it to you
exactly the kind of data and then and
then you know basically because it's all
about the data you have to you know do
validations around it you have to know
how to manage it you have to kind of you
know start making sense out of it
there's so many things that
that that you can do around it the
possibilities are endless i tell you you
know one hour is too short time to like
you probably
you know this is something we take at
least four hours
and you know you feel like going on and
on and on on that picture
oh definitely and we are planning to go
over just a little bit because i do know
that the hour ended um we had some a
couple more questions hopefully you can
get two
one of the questions is uh from uh
sumandar is there any cloud workspace to
learn hive and pick languages without
installation of a local computer so
they're a place you can go get a free
cloud
account or
obviously through simply learn part of
the class is the
our
cloud so simplyland has got a cloud
interface you can see that on my screen
right now um so you know you can start
your web console over here like this
so free cloud
is not something which is available
because cloud needs resources
and and people don't you know kind of
you know make it available for you for
free but simply learn has it uh it's so
so when you join a simply learn course
you can see that you can get this kind
of kind of an interface which is called
as cloud lab you can log into it i'm
just trying to login into it with my own
credentials at this point of time
um and and and then
you are there inside it and you can do
things like like that over here you can
find out the hadoop version so basically
it's a web based uh unix you know
console you can do your pwd over here
you can do your ls minus
you can do your ls minus l over here
night and until you know what you can
skype your start your hive shell as well
right so i believe this is what you were
you know asking for um there are no free
resources available but simplyland does
have a cloud lab with it but you get
along um you know once you join
the course over here it looks like this
i've been on the cloud lab myself and
it's really uh handy because you get to
what is it just five nodes i
think it's a yeah
it's a five node multi-node cluster yep
so you have five nodes you're actually
live so you can view them obviously you
have admin restrictions when you're on
there but you certainly get a hands-on
would be like to be working on there and
work with the different
hive and even pig and stuff like that
um
yep
uh suresh already left but thank you
suresh
uh and suman
sumandar oh my gosh i even came close
with that name
oh excellent
thank you
let's see like hbase this is from arun
like hbase does also
be used as a speed serving layer since i
could not see it in lambda architecture
guide components
so both of them are are nosql databases
but they are a different kind of you
know
nosql databases
uh edge base does more of this is more
of an implementation of google big table
which is created by big table mongodb is
more of a json format key value format
so they're different um
you know i would say different flavors
of the same uh you know same uh same
species you know how do i call it
they're the same they have the dna as
the same so they're both of them are no
dbs but
based on completely different
architectures so it's difficult to
compare them the only similarities that
you will find between the two is their
nosql databases
excellent um we have a couple questions
from different people
concerning
um because that kind of feeds right to
the next one because the mongodb
is a
unstructured data which definitely
hadoop can handle unstructured
although it's
there's also one which is all about hive
asking about structured data
and then someone else also asked
only tab separated file can be used or
hive or can we also use csv file comma
separate variable file
you can use tab separated you can see in
csv you can use json also i had due to
scarcity of time i could not
show it over here i have a couple of
samples which
you can save a json format and you can
vary those nested formats on top of it
so text is not the only thing that it
supports or comma separate is not the
only thing it supports it supports a lot
of other comments as well
richard excellent yes excellent um let's
see let's go to
uh let's see
whether hive is useful in etl
for those who don't know et well i'll
let you go ahead and go over etl for
transforming data to required format
uh
no not really our transforming data to
the required format is something which
is best done by mapreduce
not with hive hive is more of
presentation more of querying more of
you know writing queries on top of your
uh
on top of your on top of the analytics
which has already been done in the life
cycle
so
heavy duty work will be mostly done by
mapreduce and pink hype is just going to
you know help you execute queries on top
of the result that it's getting that
you're getting out of my produce and
pick so transformation you cannot do
doing hives no you cannot do that
excellent yeah that's that's what i have
my understanding
and then i guess we always this is a
question that i see a lot coming from
people who are just starting into
the hadoop framework is it necessary to
know java to learn hadoop that's from
sanjiv yes it is pretty much and
even if you're not you know aware of
java at least one programming language
is required because if you come to my
classes what happens is that the initial
you know three or four sessions are nice
and fine with fundamentals and
everything which you understand very
well but come fifth or sixth session you
know i start showing a lot of eclipse
like this which becomes scary if you
don't have programming language or java
programming language kind of interface
so you need to have
don't have the knowledge don't worry
simply learn has so if you see these
courses over here
um
how do i do that
let me
open this like this over here for you
and show this to you so simply then when
you join the courses what happens is
that you get a java and such as for
hadoop course uh along with it and it is
a good course
uh if you don't my badge what happens is
i give usually people uh a set of slides
some 7080 slides with system for you to
kind of jump on little bit data
along with the code which is there on my
uh on my google drive
welcome to the big data
developer
with everyone so see this is a big deal
on how to develop a course if i get into
the details of it you can see that no no
no no please don't start one second
uh
there you are let me just get back to it
hey everyone
yep
let's see so let's see
there you are so pick it up developer
you've got javascript for hadoop you can
go inside you can get to know about java
in detail and then i have got certain
like you know this with me that you can
go through so there are a lot of things
you can do to before
before you get started the course
excellent excellent and
just a quick reminder you can get a copy
of the session just go to the simply
learn help and support and request a
copy it does take up to 24 hours
we have time for just a couple more
questions
um
that'll take me just a moment here cuz
we got so many questions coming in
there's somebody asking about
covering the cloudera hadoop
certification certification
richard uh as much as i know uh simply
learn currently is in the process of
upgrading the course to cloudera
certification
no later than uh
next one or two months at the max
towards the end of the year uh the
course is going to get retrofitted with
cloudera certification
um so so very soon i think if you talk
to the sales people or learn some
learning development specialist and in
in and simply learn it should they
should be able to kind of you know give
your complete information about it uh
but as far as i know about the courses
this is what this very soon it will get
updated to cloud certificate by the way
uh richard cloudy certification is no
more a mcq it's more of a you know
cluster-based uh cluster-based uh
certification where you get use cases
and you have to develop you have to
implement them on a on a
multi-multi-node cluster
okay
okay i was wondering about that myself
because i haven't done the cloudera
looked into it i just started looking
into that
actually what richard i have got some
very nice quick trips uh tricks
i'm talking about trips see again
um some nice little tricks which i can
uh share with you uh which are just
just right to do your cloud
certificate i like kind of you know pop
them to you uh you know later on
okay definitely
um i appreciate that
we have a question can we partition
external
um tables
you can partition
yes you can partition external table as
well and this is a question which is
coming from somebody who's already
worked in hive yes you can partition
external table yes you can partition
internal table you can partition all
kind of tables
right you can definitely do that
see the the way to create table is you
have to create a source table and then a
destination table the destination table
becomes a partition table so you have to
create an external table which is which
is non-partition create a destination
table which is partition or the data
from the source to the destination
external table becomes party as simple
as that
that's how you can call excellent
partitioning you know excellent
excellent
we are going to go ahead and close the
session we had a number of other
questions which unfortunately
um like we could spend a whole session
explaining how ombari and spark sit on
top of hadoop
um i don't know
hopefully we'll do a demo specifically
on spark i'd like to see that because
that itself is a large area
i keep i keep doing that doing demos all
the time
richard we can share this link with the
participants which basically is the link
to i'm sure you'd also would have it
which have the link to all the webinar
that you know
simply learn keeps conducting
so so it's there on my screen you know i
can share it with you
with all the participants and here you
can get the idea about what all what all
webinars simply don't do so like you
know for example i have my these
upcoming web webinars uh
you know next week
on 12 september
there's one on 14 september so you know
the participants can kind of log in and
attend that
excellent uh great reference for anybody
who had some more questions we weren't
able to get to
you can look at the different hadoop
ones the machine learning's coming up
that'll be a good one also
and then we're going to go ahead and
close the session for today
i want to thank everybody for showing up
did you have anything else you want to
add
syed
no i'm i'm i'm pretty good
okay
excellent all right until next time it's
great talking with you syed it's great
having everybody here uh happy learning
and welcome to simply learn and
everybody take care and enjoy either the
evening or the morning or the rest of
your day depending on where you're at
and what you have going on
thank you so much richard thank you so
much it's always a pleasure to talk to
you and thank you so much all the
participants for attending the session
uh all the best to you and god bless
you